Hãy theo chung tưởng Mỹ, Wench ở liên ngoại trường Mỹ, phục trách và đề chính trị vào quan sư ông Mark Tee Kimet,
thời gian qua về tấn công dữ ưu thế trách lối trên trên trường đang dần khác lại khi công nghệ phòng thu vả trẻ mạnh mẽ.
Ông dần trứng hệ thống đánh trạng là dẻ công xuất lớn của Israel và các bạn pháp phòng về địa từ hiện đại.
Năng làm phí dạm hiệu quả của UAV trong thực chiến tại UGNa,
giù qua về tình rút của lỗi nãy bụ đáp trình là khó lực,
tạo hiệu ứng trên thông và gây tổng thất trúng à, nhưng các lực lượng đối phương đã nhánh trong thực ở bằng các bạn pháp phát hiện sớm,
nguy trang và trống nhé ốc, cùng lúc, nhiều cua ra đang lâu từ vào ra đã đa tần vũ khí đánh trạng trên biệt và chỉ tôi nhấn tạo để xây dương hệ thống phòng không từ đậm quá.
Rù vầy, UAV vẫn chưa lỗi thời,
hụi quay nà tiếp tục tận dụng yêu tổng bất ngờ và trình 2 số lượng lớn,
yêu tổng mắt theo ông Kimet, rút vui chỉ và trọng của UAV trên trên trường.
Tuy nhiên ông này nhìn mắt, kính mừng UAV bất khả sân phạm đã kết thúc,
mở ra ra ra đoạn mới của chính trái công nghệ cao có tình đủ trọng gió dễ.